I have for you today some of the absolutely
strangest video so far of Donald Trump's presidency
and that is a really high bar given that almost
all the video we have of Donald Trump has
been extraordinarily strange and bizarre.
Donald Trump complained about the flushing
of toilets 10 to 15 times and about certain
light bulbs that he doesn't like.
He talked about toilets or maybe it sinks
and showers not getting any water.
None of it made any sense.
It sort of seemed like it was maybe an attempt
at humor, but Trump really has no sense of
humor.
Some of it seemed like thinly veiled compliment
complaints rather about energy efficiency
standards that exist including around light
bulbs.
It was a word salad to end all word salad.
It was a three star Michelin rated word salad
from Donald Trump.
Let's take a look at the video, see if we
can figure anything out.
Uh, let's listen to this first one.
But together were defending the American workers
were using common sense.
We have a situation where we're looking very
strongly at sinks and showers and other elements
of bathrooms where uh, you turn the faucet
on and areas where there's tremendous amounts
of water where the water rushes out to see
because you could never handle it and you
don't get any water.
You turn on the faucet, you don't get any
water.
They take a shower and water comes dripping
out.
It's cripping out very quietly dripping out.
People are flushing toilets 10 times, 15 times
as opposed to once they ended up using more
water.
So EPA is looking at that very strongly at
my suggestion.
You go into a new building or a new house
or new home and they have standards on where
you don't get water, you can't, you can't
wash your hands practically.
This old little water comes out of the faucet
and the end result is you leave the faucet
on and it takes you much longer to wash your
hand.
You end up using the same amount of water.
So we're looking at very seriously at opening
up the standard and a, there may be some areas
where we'll go the other route, desert areas,
but for the most part you have many States
where they have so much water that it comes
down and it's called rain that they don't
know.
They don't know what to do with it.
We're looking very strongly at sinks, showers
and elements of bathrooms.
They take a shower and water drips.
People are flushing toilets 10 times.
What is Trump doing that?
Uh, he's flushing a toilet 10 to 15 times
for that.
It sounds reasonable or likely to him.
That's one question that this raises maybe
one for a different day.
How can any Trump supporter see this stuff
and see strength or leadership or intelligence
or cutting or cleverness?
How I, I need someone to explain it to me
please.
Here's another clip about the light bulbs
and we're doing other things.
The light bulb, uh, they got rid of the light
bulb that people got used to.
The new bulb is many times more expensive.
And I hate to say it, it doesn't make you
look as good.
Of course, being a vain person that's very
important to me.
Gives you an orange look.
I don't want an orange.
Has anyone noticed that?
So we'll have to change those bulbs in at
least a couple of rooms where I am in the
room.
I saw some uh, Trumpist comments, comments
online where they are just fully convinced
that this is all comedy.
Like it's all humor beyond just Trump doesn't
want to look orange.
That's true.
But the toilets, the showers, it's all humor
according to some online Trumpist enclaves.
If that's the case, what's the joke?
Like what is the joke about flushing a toilet
10 to 15 times?
It's like when Trump said windmill wind farms
caused cancer and some supporters said, Oh,
that was a joke.
That was comedy.
Well, like what, what's the joke?
What's the punchline?
I don't understand how that even qualifies
as a joke.
This was the line during the campaign.
You might recall every outrageous thing that
Donald Trump said was defended either as,
listen, Trump's just telling it like it is.
He's not being politically correct.
You won't hear this from a lot of other politicians,
but Trump is just telling it like it is.
Or the other explanation for equally crazy
comments was he doesn't literally mean everything.
He says, these are jokes.
This is humor.
You've got to stop taking it also seriously,
because Donald Trump isn't actually speaking
seriously.
We'll well, is it [inaudible]?
Is it, is it that everything is a joke or
that everything is serious and it's a truth
that nobody else is willing to tell you.
But in all seriousness, assuming that this
does all relate to building codes, if we want
to try to assess what policy might this actually
be related to, it's Trump saying he doesn't
like all the building coal codes and he wants
to look at getting rid of them.
This is another attack on sustainability.
Uh, this is yet another attempt to undo environmental
regulations at every opportunity.
Uh, even because of this vague ridiculous
people are flushing toilets 10 to 15 times
confusion.
And that's the policy concern that underlies
this, that we shouldn't forget at every opportunity
that there an opportunity to either undo an
environmental regulation or just undo something
that Barack Obama did because that's also
another priority.
It doesn't apply in all of these cases.
They are doing it and the list of things that
the next president will hopefully have to
undo or redo as the, as the case may, may
more accurate, accurately be stated, is a
growing list.
And this stuff matters.
I mean, I know that, you know, we've talked
before Elizabeth Warren, she was asked during
a recent debate for the government get to
tell you what kind of light bulbs you use.
And Elizabeth Warren astutely said, that's
the wrong question.
A hundred companies are responsible for 70
something percent of all emissions in this
country.
The pollution, the question of straw, or I
think it was actually not about light bulbs,
but maybe it was about straws.
The issue of straws is not really the big
issue.
What we have here are much, much bigger issues
to tackle.
They mostly relate to industry, but if you
look at the entire country's building and
construction industry, and you look at these
guidelines and environmental standards, they
do make a difference in the aggregate and
to laugh them off or to pretend that the government
wants you to have a crappy toilet that can't,
you know, that Trump needs to flush 10 times
because of whatever he's doing or whatever
the case may be.
It's another one of these distractions and
it is.
Yet another way that this sort of onus or
priority for dealing with the environmental
destruction is at the individual level.
It's the toilet I choose.
It's the straw that I choose when there are
much bigger issues and they're re deregulating
there as well.
I think it's important not to forget bizarre
video.
Again, just kooky video, but it does connect
to serious issues related to regulation and
the environment and climate change.
Make sure you're following the David [inaudible]
Pacman show on Instagram at David Pakman show.
Make sure you're also following me on instagram@daviddotpeck